Okay,
let's start up.
So last time we got to the point of asking the question,
are there atoms and molecules and we'll,
I anticipate that the answer is yes.
And what force holds the atoms together?
Because if we really understand the force that holds him,
we got chemistry all solved.
Okay.
So when you come to the idea of,
of forces in the,
in the first place,
one goes back to Newton and the Principia Mathematica
and he,
he had the idea or developed the idea of the mathematics of gravity.
And the interesting thing about it was there was no mechanism for it.
There were no springs or strings that connected to things,
right?
It was action at a distance.
So there were other ideas like Descartes had the idea that gravity resulted from
blocked repulsion,
that the universe was Philip Particle zipping around and bombarding thing.
So like the moon would be bombarded by particles from all directions,
but there'd be no net force on it because they'd all balance out.
However,
if you put the earth in the way,
there'd be a shadow and now you'd have more things hitting the moon from the
right than from the left.
So it would seem to be attracted to the earth.
Okay,
so that's a great mechanism.
Right now it was important for Newton that the force be proportional to r
squared
to inverse r squared,
one over r squared.
Does this work for that?
If you pulled the earth back,
how would you change things?
What'd he say?
It does,
it doesn't work.
What would it block more or fewer things?
If you pulled it back,
how many fewer?
Suppose you made it twice as far back.
How many fewer would would be blocked from hitting the moon?
It would be,
it would be one over r squared.
Even think about that.
So that would,
that,
that aspect of it would work.
How about,
you know,
gravity is proportional to the mass of the things.
How does that figure,
you can think about that yourself.
Okay.
But anyhow,
there were other ideas,
but Newton didn't think about the mechanism.
He thought about the law,
right?
That it was one over r squared and proportional to the masses.
Now in 1717 he published the second edition of optics,
right?
He published the first edition in 17 four and the reason that he published it in
[inaudible] 17 for was that Robert Hooke died in 17 three he'd actually,
Newton had done this work in the,
in the 1660s and seventies but he didn't publish it until hope died because he
didn't want hook to get on his case criticizing it,
right?
But in the second edition,
in 1717 he put some additional material you'll see with additions and the
additional material,
even though the book is about optics,
the additional material is about chemistry,
right?
So,
and it's at the end and posed not as hypotheses,
but as questions because May Konijn people following Francis Bacon weren't
supposed to make hypotheses that they could ask questions.
So here are some of the questions.
Question 31 the one that has most to do with chemistry have not the small
particles of bodies,
certain powers,
virtues or forces by which they act at a distance,
not only on the rays of light to reflect,
reflect an inflect them,
but also upon one another for producing a great part of the phenomena of nature
that is attraction between the particles or repulsion for its will known that
bodies act upon one another by the attractions of gravity,
magnetism and electricity.
And these instances show the tenor in course of nature and make it not
improbable,
but that there may be more attractive powers than these for nature is very
consonant and conformable to herself.
How these attractions may be performed,
I do not hear,
consider
what I call attraction may be performed by impulse.
Where did he get that idea?
Where did he get the idea that their impulses that can cause attraction.
That was Descartes' idea,
right?
That we just explained.
Okay.
Uh,
or by some other means unknown to me.
I use that word here to signify only in general,
any force by which bodies tend toward one another whatsoever.
Be the cause for,
we must learn from the phenomena of nature,
what bodies attract one another and what are the laws and properties of
attraction before we inquire the caused by which the attraction is performed.
Right?
So get the law first so you can do mathematics on it.
Then worry about how it works.
The attractions of gravity,
magnetism,
and electricity react to very sensible distances.
He doesn't mean reasonable.
He means ones that you can sense and so have been observed by vulgar eyes.
You can see the distance is over which electrostatic attraction works.
Obviously gravity,
magnetism,
and there may be others which reached to so small distances as hither to to
escape observation.
And perhaps electrical attraction may reach to such small distances even without
being excited by friction.
So you know that friction can generate static electricity does make things
attract,
but maybe even without friction you can get things that will attract very short
distance by electricity.
The parts of all homogeneous,
all hard bodies,
which fully touch one another stick together very strongly.
Did you ever have that experience of having to really flat things,
put them together and they're very hard to get apart.
What
microscopes slides do you ever take out new microscope slides?
It can be very hard to get apart
and for explaining how this may be some of invented hooked Adams,
which is begging the question and others tell us that bodies are glued together
by rest that is by an occult quality or rather by nothing and others that they
stick together by conspiring motions that is by relative rests among themselves.
These are other theories that are sort of complicated.
We don't need to go into,
I had rather infer from their cohesion that there are particles attract one
another by some force,
which in immediate contact is exceeding strong at small distances,
performs the chemical operations above mentioned and reaches not far from the
particles with any sensible effect.
So a very short range,
very strong attraction reaches not far from the particles with any sensible
effect.
So maybe it's even more dramatic than one over r squared.
One over r squared changes very rapidly when art gets very small.
But maybe it's even a law that's more,
more distance dependence than that.
That only works at really,
really small distances.
The attraction,
and he's talking about between glass plates separated by a thin film of the oil
of oranges.
So,
you know,
microscope slides,
if you put a little drop us up and stick them together,
they're really hard to get apart.
May Be proportionally greater the attraction and continue to increase until the
thickness did not exceed that of a single particle of oil.
Imagine Newton
350 years ago or 300 years ago here,
uh,
thinking about a single particle of oil.
How could he,
could he possibly measure that?
We'll think about that later.
Okay.
There are there for agents in nature able to make the particles of bodies stick
together by very strong attractions and it is the business of experimental
philosophy to find them out.
That's what we need to find.
What is it that holds these particles together?
Experimental philosophy means science.
Okay.
And we're gonna engage this business and it'll take us about five weeks to
figure out what it is that holds these things together.
Okay.
Now,
let's just look at from physics at the amount of binding energy you get from
different kinds of laws.
First,
there's cool ohms law,
so charges over the distance.
I think you all know that one.
Then there's magnetic interaction to magnetic dipoles.
The energy,
the energy is one over r cubed falls off very rapidly.
Then there's the strong binding that holds particles together in the nuclei of
atoms and gravitation of course,
and the chemical bond.
So here's the scale of energies and we use in this course the old fashioned
kilocalories per mole,
which American organic chemists like to use.
Some day it'll change to kill the jewels per bowl,
but for me it's still kilocalories per mole.
Okay?
This is a logarithmic scale,
so it covers a very wide range.
Now Coolum if you have a proton and an electron as far apart as the distance of
a carbon carbon bond,
that's 216 kilocalories per mole,
right in the middle of this or near the middle,
magnetic interaction is much weaker.
If you have two electron spins at the same distance from one another,
their energy is what?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five orders of magnitude smaller,
10 to the fifth smaller,
the strong binding that holds a proton and the neutron together in the deuterium
nucleus that is within the nucleus,
not at 1.54 Ostrom's is 10 to the fifth stronger than Coolum Vic interaction.
And gravity is ever so much weaker.
If you had two carbon atoms that were at that distance,
the energy would be 10 to the minus 32 kilocalories from also forget gravity as
a way of holding things together,
right?
Uh,
but then we have Coolum buck up or down by 10 orders of by five orders of
magnitude right.
Now what does a chemical bond,
how strong is it?
A chemical bond is about the carbon carbon bond is about 90 kilocalories per
mole.
So not so far from the Coolo energy from electrostatic attraction.
So maybe this hints that electrostatic attraction has something to do with it,
but maybe not.
Maybe it's something entirely new.
And
we haven't talked about kinetic energy.
Does that have anything to do with the strength of the bond?
So we'll get back to that later on.
Okay.
So is there a chemical force law,
the thing that Newton was looking for?
Now,
Here's interesting way to phrase that.
Suppose you had a chain of Adam's,
a thread that was single atoms bonded to one another and you started stretching
it.
It would stretch and at some point it would pop.
Okay,
now let's just take three of the atoms and we'll put stiff rods on the outer
ones and we'll start stretching it a little stretch,
stretch,
Strout
pop.
Okay?
Now the question is how far do you stretch it before it pops?
What determines how far you stretch it before it pops?
Okay,
this must have to do with the forest law between Adams,
which will then we'll have to do with molecular structure,
so it could be like springs,
Hooke's law,
Atencio,
sick viess.
Okay,
so the forest is proportional to the displacement and the energy to the square
of the displacement and the energy.
Then potential energy as a Parabola,
we defined zero when they're at the standard on unstretched distance,
and then you stretch it or compress it,
the energy goes up like a parabola.
Okay?
Now the slope of that parabola tells you what
the force,
that's what's linear.
As we stretch it further and further,
the slope gets bigger.
The force is proportional to the displacement,
okay?
Now they're put,
there could be other kinds of forest laws like electrical charges,
Kula more gravity.
Okay?
So that's a different forest law in diverse square force law.
And the energy then is proportional to uh,
the displacement,
okay?
In this way,
so very different.
Notice the zero of this one's at the top.
When it's zero defined,
when they're very far apart here,
it's zero when they're at the standard distance,
okay?
So as you bring charged oppositely charged particles forever together,
the energy goes down infinitely as they get really close,
okay?
And now if we look at the forest here,
as we go out,
the forest gets smaller,
the slope gets smaller,
okay?
Now suppose you had a particle that was connected to a spring on each side as in
this chain that we're stretching.
And just to be general,
I made the second string,
uh,
oh,
I say stronger.
It's in fact weaker,
right?
It doesn't go up as rapidly.
I'll have to change that.
Okay.
Now,
but at some point the slopes of the red and the blue at some distance,
some position will be equal and opposite there.
Okay.
What's the force on the PR?
The central particle at that point?
Zero.
They balanced,
right?
So if we add those two energies together to get the sum of the two on the
central,
it looks like that.
Okay,
so there's a balance to minimum.
There's a well defined position where the particle in the center of this chain,
we'll just sit there and it'll be hard to display so it can vibrate.
Okay.
Now how about in the other case?
How about if it were electrical charges or gravity or something like that and
inverse square law that's holding things together.
Then the second one is going to look like that and that one is indeed stronger.
So there are two flanking bodies and we're interested in the position to the one
in the middle,
right.
And again,
there'll be some point where they balance right there.
Okay.
Where they're equal and opposite slopes.
How will this differ from the first case?
Can you see what's going to happen when we add these two together
because they're going to look more or less like the one on the left.
It's going to look like that and now there is no balanced minimum in the middle.
There is not a position where the thing will just sit there because it's always
more strongly effected and attracted by the one that's closer to,
there's some place where there's zero force but it's not a stable position as if
it displaces ever so slightly.
It'll keep on going.
So that one is for the two of them is a single minimum and this one is a double
minimum.
And for the people who came early,
there was a contest that if you want it,
you could get an a in the course.
And the contest is this,
here's a magnet
hanging here
and I'll stop it.
Okay.
And here are two magnets,
the ones that will flank that one.
And if I get it just right,
it'll just sit there.
Right.
The attraction to the two will balance.
I'll put it on here
and try to get my a,
so I'll get this drain where it would balance right there.
Ah,
okay.
There is no stable position.
Nobody got there a that
right,
because it's at the end of verse law,
right?
So it's always more strongly attracted to the closer thing,
So you can't win with that.
You can't get a balanced position.
Let me get these off here
and back to the show.
So with springs,
you might be able to make a stable polyatomic molecule from point Adams.
We saw a spring model before in the last lecture,
but you can't do it with ions and you can't do it with magnets.
However,
Hooke's law can't do it.
Can't be springs because Hooke's law never breaks.
So we need a different kind of force law.
Can anybody,
does anybody know a forest law that what it looks like?
The form of the forest between the atoms or the energy for stretching a bond?
You ever seen a picture of such a thing?
It's called the Morris potential,
or one form of it at least is called the Morris potential.
And it's not something fundamental.
It's not a law of nature.
It was thought up by a physicist at Princeton in 1929 because it's
mathematically convenience.
So you could solve quantum mechanical problems if he used Morris potentials.
Okay.
And the idea is this,
you have two neighbors,
right?
And you look at the position to the one on the right and it could be there and
the energy would be minimum.
That's the bond distance,
right?
And if you move it further to the right,
the energy goes up,
move it to the left,
the energy goes up.
Okay,
that's the more potential.
And we're just holding the,
the neighbor on the left fixed.
Now we could put another neighbor on the other side,
right?
And have another curve of the same sort that re that's stretching the second
bond.
Or we could have it be a chain and have both neighbors there.
Right?
And the sum of those two now has a minimum in the middle.
It's a single minimum,
like we got with Hooke's law.
So that means that Adam in the middle would just stay there and now we're going
to grab those sticks on either side and pull the neighbors apart.
So if we pull them apart,
it's still a single minimum.
And if we pull them apart further,
it's still a single minimum,
although it's very flat.
And if we pull it further,
it pops and it becomes a double minimum.
And if we keep going,
the double minimum gets more pronounced.
Now here's an interesting question.
At what point,
how far do you have to stretch it before it pops?
That's the question we were asking,
right?
How can you look at those curves and tell how far apart you have to stretch it
before the chain pops?
What do you mean flat?
There's a name for a thing like that in the graph.
It's the inflection point.
It's when the curvature changes from being this way,
like Hooke's law to being this way,
right?
So when the inflection points cross them,
the chain pops.
Okay,
so forest laws are going to make a lot of difference in how atoms behave.
And we real,
if we really knew the forest law,
we'd be in a great position for understanding chemistry.
It snaps at the inflection point where it changes from an direct to an inverse
dependence on distance for force.
Okay,
but what are bonds,
right?
Newton said,
we'll look for the law and it's sort of the law as sorta like Morse,
but we don't know where it came from because we don't know how it works.
We don't know what it really is.
So can we find out what it really is?
Well,
in the 19th century they discovered bonds,
right?
And this is a picture from 1861 we'll talk about this later.
And it's one of the first depictions that's recognizable by people today of
bonds between atoms.
So there are different numbers of these lines violences for different atoms.
Hydrogen has one,
carbon has four oxygen to nitrogen,
three.
Right?
Why do the elements differ?
Why don't they all have the same valence?
Right?
And even more complicated.
Sometimes nitrogen is three and sometimes it's five for example,
you have Nh three,
but you also have Nh four cl where there five things associated with the
nitrogen.
Right?
So how do you understand the valence?
That was the challenge for people.
They had figured out that there was valence,
but why?
How could you predict the valence of a new element?
Well,
Gertrude and Robin,
Robert Robinson published a paper in 1977 17 which showed this picture of
ammonia Nh three.
What's the loop?
Pardon me?
Someone's holding your hand up so people can hear you.
Okay.
Yes.
A lone pair on nitrogen wrong.
It looks like the lone bear on nitrogen,
but the loan period didn't come along that soon.
What the loop means,
if you look at it in a context,
is what makes Nh three reactive.
In this term,
this is what they wrote.
It may reasonably be assumed that the partial dissociation is a stage in the
complete process.
So the bonds begin to break this loop because the break to become a weeper loop
and two other partial valence in this theory,
and those valances begin to associate with partial valence from hcl.
That's called the loop is a latent valence.
You know what latent means?
Latent is the opposite of Peyton's or patent.
Latent means hidden.
Patent is revealed.
When you get a patent on something,
it means that you tell everybody how to do it,
but the government protects your right to do it for a certain period of time.
Late means it's hidden.
So there's a hidden valence,
these loops,
but they could become available,
right?
It must be assumed.
Some cases,
there's,
for example,
the combination of ammonia with hydrochloric acid.
Now,
so you get a reaction and get the product,
which has all five valence as of nitrogen now,
but how do you know there's not another loop on nitrogen that you could break
open and make it seven valence or nine or 11
or maybe you could break a loop into three.
Right?
So Mike Layton Valence loop explained the tribe,
valence and pentavalent of nitrogen or the Amine Hcl reactivity.
The trouble is it's too slippery a concept and explains everything.
You could explain anything you wanted to.
You could just play an 84 valence of nitrogen or something.
Right?
Anything that comes along and say,
Aha there that many latent valence is,
but how do you know they're not more right?
Why do you have late and says,
when do you have them?
Right when and why do you have partial dissociation?
This thing didn't explain anything or explained everything.
Now at this point,
I want you to smile so I can learn who you are.
Okay?
So I've got to go see the,
see the ivory is here.
[inaudible]
last year I had to do this twice because by hands shook first.
Okay.
No,
I have to get your people back here
someday I'll get a fancier Cameron single shot.
We'll do the whole thing.
Yeah.
I don't know if I got you here.
[inaudible] big smile
and
I don't know if I can get you all in one and not quite get you all by yourself.
[inaudible]
people from Hawaii.
Very distinguished.
Okay,
thank you.
So the electron was discovered in 1897
right?
So maybe that has something to do with it.
And the guy who associated electrons with valence was GN Lewis.
And this is a picture of him as a Harvard undergraduate in 1894
and this is eight years later when he was an instructor at Harvard.
And he then went to establish the chemistry department at the University of
California at Berkeley.
But when he was at Harvard in 19 two he had,
he used these lecture notes and what he was trying to explain was the periodic
table,
right?
Why you go across in aid and then another eight and another eight and so on.
Right?
And how,
why you have electron transfers from some atoms to other atoms.
And he said if the electrons in an atom are arranged at the corners of a cube,
then you at eight is this very special number cause that occupies all the
corners of the cube,
right?
So if there's a desire for some reason to complete octets,
then you could explain periodicity and see why some atoms give up an electron to
lose the outer shell and others gained,
wanted to complete the outer shell.
Okay.
So,
but it also could explain how you get bonding if you like to have octets not
just electron transfer,
but the formation of covalent bonds.
So for example,
here's two chlorine's.
Each has only seven.
The octet isn't complete.
But if you bring them together and they share an edge,
then both octets are complete.
He doesn't say why octets should be so great.
But if they're octets,
then you could explain the bonds.
How about double bonds?
Suppose you had two oxygen atoms.
What do you do now?
Anybody?
See?
Yup.
Put the faces to put faces together.
Share two edges,
right?
And then both have an octet.
Now suppose you want to put nitrogens together and form a triple bond.
Now how do you do it?
Push it hard.
Force it like a picture puzzle.
Yes,
put it in there.
[inaudible] won't do it.
But in,
but about 10 years later,
he figured out how to do it.
What you do is take the electrons,
nitrogen has five,
but instead of using an octet,
you can track that along opposing edges this way.
So what was the knock tete?
What was a cube?
Becomes what
a tetrahedron,
and now if you take two tetrahedron,
you can put a face together and complete both octets,
but this wasn't such a great development.
He did this and publish this at 1916 but the tetrahedral distribution of the
bonds in carbon had been known by organic chemists for 40 years by that time
that the tetrahedron was a very important structure.
Okay,
so a good theory should be realistic and it should be simple,
but there's a tension between these things.
It should at least be as simple as possible,
right?
But that may not be very simple.
That's why it takes us five weeks.
Okay.
In regard to the facts,
it should allow a number of properties.
It should allow prediction.
You should be able to say,
how will these atoms react?
How will this molecule react?
Right?
What valence should nitrogen have?
How could it be both pentavalent and and try Vaillant?
Little below this on the scale of desirability is suggestion.
A theory may,
even if it doesn't give you the proper thing,
may at least suggest some experiment that would be really good to do.
Below that is explanation.
Right?
According to my theory,
all these known facts fit together,
but who knows about any new thing.
And the lowest is classification and remembering like you know,
Roy g bev allows you to remember the colors of the spectrum,
but there's nothing fundamental about that.
So even if you have a crummy thing,
it might allow you to help at least remember some facts,
organize them,
maybe.
Okay,
but those last two are not prediction there.
Post diction,
you only use it to explain things that are already known as a way of remembering
them.
So from the number of electrons,
we'd like to predict how,
how many atoms of different types come together to form molecules.
That's constitution,
the nature and the sequence of bonds.
And the valence.
We'd like to know the structure of molecules,
the distance between Adams angles.
We'd like to know how charges distributed within molecules.
Are some regions positive and others negative.
We'd like to know what the energy of the molecule is.
Is this arrangement of the atoms better or worse than an alternative
arrangement?
Right?
And we'd like to know about reactivity.
So Louis Explains Constitution,
the nature and the sequence of bonds,
nature of the beans,
like single,
double,
triple,
and sequence means which atoms are connected to which,
okay,
so he has electrons,
valence,
and also he added unshared payers,
right?
So you count up how many from the atomic weight or the atomic number of the
position of the periodic table.
You get how many valence electrons,
how many of these outer octet are there?
And then you can figure that the,
the valence of hydrogens should be one bar on three carbon four.
But then down again,
three,
two,
one.
Okay.
So here's ammonia and h one and three were expanding that has an unshared pair.
But why do you have octets?
Why not sextets right?
And why do you have a pair for hydrogen?
Why not an octet for hydrogen also?
Okay,
so let's just apply it to HCN.
So carbon has four and that means possible to make a single bond to hydrogen,
a triple bond to carbon.
Everybody has their octet except hydrogen that only wants to,
so everybody's happy and we can abbreviate it this way and leave the dot.
Louis actually thought of draw drawing a coal and a pair of dots to denote an
unshared bear.
So that's his notation.
So NH three.
Bingo.
How about Bh three?
Just fine.
But here's something new.
The organic chemist would already have known this.
They knew the valence numbers,
the electrons just added something to it,
but didn't say anything really new.
But here's something new that Bh three reacts with Nh three
to give a new bond.
Okay?
Now here's a puzzle.
It's also true that Bh three reacts with Bh Three.
That doesn't look like Louis.
Okay?
So we'll,
uh,
and the bond is reasonably strong.
It's half as strong as a carbon carbon bond.
Okay?
So what's the glue that holds B h six together?
And we'll come back to that,
uh,
14 lectures from now.
But there's another thing,
there's bookkeeping that you do with Lewis structures to assign what's called
formal charges,
not real charges,
just what charges you right in the formula.
And you hope they mean something.
And the bookkeeping scheme you used is that each Adam is assigned half interest
in the bonding pair.
So if there's a bonding pair for bookkeeping purposes,
you assign one electron to each.
It may be they aren't evenly shared that the bookkeepers don't care.
Incidentally,
speaking of bookkeepers not caring,
there's a,
uh,
people have had a lot of nonsense trying to get signed up for lab,
because the people who run the system,
uh,
don't allow teachers to have to have,
access to the thing to see the problems you faced.
So I have no way of telling,
I can't get onto your system.
Has everybody figured out how to sign up for lab by now?
If anybody still has problems after class,
Dr the Maglio can take you to the computer center here and help you.
So,
uh,
next year,
presumably it'll be easier.
This is a new system this year.
But anyhow,
back to the bookkeepers here.
Uh,
this,
so these formal charges are not necessarily real charges.
They're just what you write.
Do you draw the formula?
Okay,
so we split the V and electrons between the be in the end and we split the
hydrogen bonds as well.
So nitrogen now has those four electrons where it brought five to the table
originally,
right?
So it has a positive charge.
Tetra Vaillant nitrogen is positive in the Lewis structure.
Why?
Because in forming the fourth bond,
it gave up half interest in one of its electrons,
the ones in the unshared pair,
so it lost the charge and negative charge and becomes positive by the same
token.
What else can you write in this structure
that is negative,
a negative charge on Boron,
right?
Cause it got half interest in a pair,
but that's just bookkeeping.
So when you write a Lewis structure,
you'd write plus on nitrogen and minus on Boron.
Okay.
Now is it real?
Is there a positive charge on nitrogen and negative charge on Boron?
Well,
we'll get later on to to know about what a surface potential is.
Surface potential is the energy of Proton would have if it was on different
points on the molecular surface.
For this purpose,
you have to define what the surface is of of a,
B and h six.
Right?
There's a way of doing that.
We won't talk about it now that's jumping the gun.
But that's the surface and it's color coded to show the energy of Proton would
have if it were on the surface at that point.
So what you see is that the energy of the Proton would be high if it's here
where it's very blue,
the energy of the Proton would be low if it's in this region here,
right?
Is that consistent with what we were talking about?
Where would,
where would a proton be low in energy where there's negative charge and it would
be high in energy when there's positive charge.
So this molecule,
according to quantum mechanics is positive on the left and negative on the
right.
Right.
And that's exactly what we had,
right?
It's consistent with what we had.
And now Louis also explains where pentavalent nitrogen comes from because as an
ionic bond there to Tetra Vale nitrogens plus.
So there's just the Kula big attraction between ammonium and chloride.
So that's a great contribution.
Now,
there are other things you can understand in terms of Lewis structures,
like you have an Amit and it can react with an oxygen to give an amine oxide,
which is positive on nitrogen,
negative on oxygen.
Or you can have a sulfide which can react with an oxygen to give us sulfoxide or
what else could happen
with the sulfur.
What additionally could happen,
it could do another oxygen and give a sole phone as it's called.
Okay,
so Louis explains this.
So there are problems to drill on Lewis structures right there on the web.
Go look at them.
One of them is draw a Lewis dot structures for h n c in that order age then,
and we did HCN but do HNC.
Okay.
And then try HCN.
Oh,
with CNO in all six linear orders,
right?
That is nitrogen in the middle of carbon in the middle,
oxygen in the middle,
and then hydrogen on either end.
And it's also possible to make a ring of CNO and put the hydrogen on any of the
positions.
So just practice drawing Lewis structures of those.
Okay.
And start memorizing functional groups.
We do precious little memorizing in this course compared to most organic
chemistry courses.
We try to figure out how things work so that you can get without memorizing it,
but there's some things you have to know like the names of groups.
Otherwise we takes forever to talk about them.
Okay,
so here are the ones you have to learn.
And on the first exam,
uh,
coming up in three weeks or whatever,
I'll give you a question where you have to draw one of these structures from the
name or give the name for a structure.
These are all on the webpage and I have to copy them down,
but those are simple functional groups.
Okay.
Hey on here are,
whoops.
Oh,
sorry.
There they're also conjugated functional groups so you can see if you can run it
yourself.
Okay.
Now the final question here for today is a thing that comes up when you talk
about Lewis structures or structures in general.
Lewis structures in particular is equilibrium and resonance.
How many people know what residents is?
What is it?
Speak up a little bit please.
Same molecule but different structure,
but it isn't structure molecule.
If you don't mind,
let me just interject a minute here.
It's like one of the problems is HCN.
Oh,
in any order,
right?
So there would be different molecules with sea in the middle and in the middle.
Oh,
in the middle.
Is that what you mean?
Huh?
Now let's actually,
resonance is one of those things where people try to hide ignorance from
ignominy and let me show you what I mean by that.
So here's,
here's a structure for HCN.
Oh,
right.
And here it has all octets.
If you go through,
you'll figure that out.
It has charged separation though.
You don't like to have that in your structures.
You'd like not to have charges.
If you can avoid obviously be n h six you can't avoid it.
Okay?
Now,
but you can get rid of the charge separation by shifting that electron pair
that's on oxygen to be shared between oxygen and nitrogen.
Then you don't have a night the charge on oxygen anymore.
Everybody see that?
And what's the problem when you do that?
Nitrogen now has too many electrons.
So you can shift a pair from the,
that's in the CN bond onto the carbon in your drawing you make,
okay,
so you get this structure shown below,
which has all octets
but they're still charge separation and in fact it's worse because the negative
charge instead of being on oxygen is now on carbon.
Right?
So these two different Lewis structures you could draw in,
each has its own properties.
They are good things and bad things.
Now what are the geometric implications of there being two structures?
It couldn't mean that in the middle one and the lower one,
nitrogen is exactly halfway between carbon and oxygen because they're both
double bonds.
But in the top when nitrogen is much closer to and the oxygen right,
that could be the meaning of this
so that if you draw a picture of the energy as a function of the position of the
nitrogen,
you could get two different structures.
One where it's further to the left,
where the nitrogens further to the left,
you have this structure and when the nitrogen is in the middle,
you have that structure and you have to go up hill and energy.
It'll click right.
If you start pushing the nitrogen and starts,
you'll
click,
and that's the other one,
okay?
That could be the way the atoms really behave.
That's called a double minimum.
We already saw a double minimum today,
okay?
But maybe in truth,
it's not this way.
Maybe it's a single minimum
may be the best position for the nitrogen is neither to the left nor in the
middle.
But in between.
Maybe that's the lowest energy,
right?
And that is what resonance is.
Resonance is when you,
the true structure is in between the structures you draw,
right?
So really what it is is a failure of the notation
is everybody see how that,
so it's that the notation you use doesn't show the right structure.
And when that happens,
there's residents,
they're said to be residents,
although actually all it is is that the true structure is a single minimum,
not the double minimum.
You would expect from your drawing.
It's a failure of the way you draw.
And notice that for resonance you use a double headed arrow.
Whereas if I back up a second here,
equilibrium.
When you have a double minimum,
there are two arrows,
right?
Two different structures.
So the question is which is it?
Is the real molecule a double minimum or the real molecules a double minimum?
Are there two structures or is there in truth only one structure?
So you need to choose between the choice between whether there's resonance or
equilibrium must be based on experimental facts or on a theory that's better
than Louis's theory to be able to know which is true.
Something that can distinguish between a single and a double minimum.
So equilibrium is duck two arrows and there are two structures that go back and
forth.
And resonance is a single structure that our notation isn't very good at
drawing.
Okay?
So two real species or one real species,
but to reasonable formulas we could draw for it or that Louis would draw for it.
So really what it is,
resonance is a failure of simplistic notation
and it's associated with unusual stability.
Now,
what I say unusual that implies that you know what usual stability is.
So compared to what is it unusual,
and we'll address that question later on.
So let me just give you finally an example of equilibrium versus resonance.
So this,
as you'll learn when you learn functional groups is a carboxylic acid and you
could have the hydrogen attached to this oxygen or it could be attached to the
other oxygen.
So these are not just the same thing upside down.
It's the hydrogen being attached to one or being attached to the other of the
two oxygens.
And it could in fact it is that way.
There are two structures and you go back and forth between them,
okay,
two species.
But how about if you take the hydrogen atom away and have this thing that's
called a free radical where you don't have a complete octet on this oxygen,
there are only two,
four,
six,
seven electrons there.
It has the ability to form another bond by sharing an electro,
right?
Is that two different species,
or is it one species?
Watch
with an intermediate geometry where you don't really have double and single
bonds,
but something in between.
And how do you know which it is?
The only way is to do some experiment that tells you,
and there is an experiment that tells you it's only one nuclear geometry,
and we don't have time in the last 30 seconds to tell you how that proof works.
But I'll tell you that the technique is electron paramagnetic resonance
spectroscopy shows that in truth,
although this is two species,
this is one species,
so there's equilibrium at the top,
at residence,
at the bottom,
and if you add an extra electron to make a Carbox late,
and ion infrared spectroscopy tells you that it's symmetrical too.
There's resonance in this case,
it's an intermediate structure,
but that is lore,
right?
You didn't predict that from Lewis structure ahead of time.
It could have been either way.
Right?
In fact,
there were many people that thought it was one way or the other.
It's only experiment that does it.
So next time we'll talk more about lore.